so this this is going to be quite a
technical demonstration of a
library that we're developing and it's
going to be live in the notebook so
hopefully it's all going to go very well
and honestly I'm not masking the fact
that this was last minute preparation
and I might have only just prepared it
this morning so please please bear with
me okay so am so in the meta fists we're
dealing with an awful lot of gridded
data so that's kind of maybe longitude
by latitude by height by time by
ensemble and awful lots of time so we're
dealing with pretty big numpy are raised
and one of the ways that we're trying to
make our scientists live easier is to
develop a library which kind of brings
together the various file formats that
we have to ingest into a common data
model that we can then do analysis psalm
and pump out results so this library is
called iris and kind of the the
interfaces is pretty straightforward I'm
not going to talk about iris here but
essentially this is a kind of a sample
netcdf file that we that we might load
it contains four variables and an array
which of for each which is kind of
pretty high dimensional and in order to
have any kind of performance from this
we really don't want to have to load
when we load the file we don't really
have to have these arrays which are just
an umpire rates in memory so we need we
needed a tool which allowed us to have
arrays bigger than the memory that was
available to us that we're efficient and
knew how to access the underlying data
for what they represent
so once we've got the kind of big array
we need also to be able to index down
reduce the actual size of the arrays
without having to get hold of the full
realize the whole array and just be able
to index into subsets we also have we
get an awful lot of files and they kind
of come together into into a bigger
array so we might we might separate our
data bye-bye time step for instance so
we needed to be able to concatenate
these arrays efficiently what we didn't
need which i think is important to know
we don't need ragged arrays so we have
got orthogonal data it fills an umpire
ray we don't need we just need one beta
type we typically use floats or or
Institute's but but it's it's constant
within the the variable that we're
talking about and we don't really need
amazing performance we just need to be
able to do the analyses in the first
place because some these are raising
pretty big and the tools don't exist for
us to be able to produce the analyses
okay so as I say there are there are
some tools that already exist and are
under development blaze being quite an
interesting one in that front but we
think they're quite ambitious and and
not quite ready for the big time just
yet so we did what any self-respecting
software engineer I would do and your
own library and the library is called
biggest and and I'm talking about a
pretty early version here so we've got
milk point five this is development
branch
so biggest at its heart implements an
array class which expresses it an
interface that you will be pretty
familiar with with an umpire race on top
of that it's really simple by the way on
top of that and we've got a subclass of
that array which is just a container so
we can create bigger surveys from
another array so in this case actually
I'm just going to make an umpire ray and
I'm going to pop that into our numpy
array adapter ok and want to print that
it's just an adapter on the original
array it knows its shape and this is
data type it's pretty simple so you
can't read that because of the screen
but basically the containment concept is
is really important in biggis it allows
us to do an awful lot of things that
aren't really possible with things like
numpy where it's quite hard to subclass
the ndarray ok so like numpy we can do
things like concatenation and we have a
race of class called linear mosaic and
essentially the normal numpy concatenate
takes a list of a race and axis and it
will join join so I just got a 700 x 200
here during the two together on the axis
0 in this case make a 14 x 200 and you
can do the same with with biggest using
this linear music takes a list of arrays
an axis but the important thing to note
the really significant difference here
between what numpy does and what biggest
does and is that in order to create that
that bigger array numpy actually has to
allocate the memory and copy the
the two arrays into that memory buffer
what we're doing is we're just
containing the original arrays so
there's no no copying of memory it's
just just smart and is what's due again
I can I could show you that doesn't
really matter what access we work on
numpy increases to 700 x 400 so it is
biggest okay so as well as as well as
concatenation type behavior we've added
a stack type behavior so we called it a
linear mosaic where essentially it's not
what I was expecting to happen oh no my
apologies and so the the real benefit
there is that we can just make a pretty
long list of a raise and stack them
together and instantly we get quite a
big array without having to copy memory
around it's pretty pretty neat so this
is what I was actually meant to talk
about the stack so we can also create a
new dimension with an array stack and
that just takes a an array of array
object and it gives us a new dimension
so we're going to I've got 200 x 700 x
200 a 2 x 700 x 200 again same
properties no copying needed
ok
and so one of the inputs we just saw was
an umpire rain but technically that's
not really that useful to us and so one
thing we like to be able to do is pass
through other types of array like
objects into our adapter and in this
case I've got an example of loading hdf5
file I'm pulling out a variable called a
range and and I'm popping that into the
numpy array adapter ok so my array now
knows its size it knows the data type
but it hasn't actually read the the data
from the hdf5 file just yet it's still a
reference to the original file and in
fact if you close the the file handle
and you would never be able to realize
this big as a regiment because the files
closed but you can see that the the
adapter principle is pretty extensible I
should add that hdf5 already the hdf5
library already has like an array-like
thing where you can index into this
variable just kind of extending that to
be a bit more generic
so one of the beauties is that we don't
have to always just combine kind of limp
I adapters and adapters from hdf5 we can
we can join them together so the bigger
array that I had earlier on which was
created from Limp I adapters so from
actual tangible Empire raised I'm going
to join that together with the hdf array
and instantly you have using the same
same stuff that we had previously
instantly you've got an array which is a
bigger shape which combines together the
data from different sources
so going back this array here I said
when you were when you were passing
through the hdf5 variable we're not
actually realizing the array and and one
of the concepts with biggest is that you
have to tell it when you're ready for it
to realize these arrays so you do that
with the ndr a method on the on the
object and that will then go away and
essentially create the numpy array for
you so it's at that point that you're
going to need enough memory in order to
hold onto this
as you kind of expect with arrays and
Limp I like things you can index these
biggest erase and it essentially does
what you'd expect and it's pretty smart
in that we've just indexed across the
scene of two different sources one from
a plane an umpire rate and one from an
hdf5 variable it just works so one of
the reasons we're doing this is a we
don't want to have to have all of these
variables in memory at the same time but
also we have quite a lot data pretty
pretty big data which we can't fit into
memory so we've implemented an engine on
top of the biggest arrays which
essentially chunks your arrays into into
smaller components and does the
processing on each chunk and then brings
it back together for you into an array
so in order to do that we've got biggest
mean and the normal operations and
you'll find that they're pretty quick
and they're quick because they're
deferred as I say the operations haven't
taken place yet we only have a reference
to the original array that we just
passed and under and context of what
operation needs to take place on it okay
and as soon as we do the realization as
soon as we call this md array in both
places that is when the the operation
takes place so here I'm just I'm
printing the aggregation before it
actually happens and it knows the shape
of the of the result so there's some
context there about knowing what taking
the mean over axis 00 actually means and
then I'm just showing you the results
are identical
okay so right so when we were doing
those two operations we did a mean and
standard deviation in order to calculate
those with numpy in the traditional
sense you would have to iterate over the
whole array and do your analysis and
then it's right over the whole array and
do the slightly different analysis but
if you've got a raise which may be a
bigger than like the can fit in memory
then what you really want to be able to
do is as we're chunking through those
there's blocks we do the two analyses at
the same time so so you had a length
million array you want to do 10,000
10,000 10,000 taking the mean and
standard deviation of each you should go
along so in order to do that we've got
this this function here which basically
realizes the the to aggregation objects
the mean and standard deviation they
were the things that we compute it from
the arrays and we can then see that the
result from realizing this using the ND
arrays function is actually an empire
ray it's quite hard to show you this
doing magical things on a laptop in real
time but it really is chunking your
arrays into smaller components doing the
operations and then aggregating all back
together and giving you results
sure dad where we have an engine already
which is doing this chunk processing on
multiple threads but the performance
we're not going to see massive
performance benefit because they're
often not CPU burn them or more I oh
bond
ok
right so we have this concept where we
can hold the rays which are bigger than
that that's available in memory and we
can do operations on them and that
that's all working that's fine but if
sometimes you've got a big array and you
want to do an aggregation and the result
is another big array which isn't in a
fitted memory then you're going to need
to do some again I have to accept that
you're never going to be able to realize
that I wrecked that limp IRA into Python
so what we have is some streaming
functionality which uses the chunking
operations but is instead of chunking
into an umpire ray we can trunk directly
into hdf5 variable or netcdf verbal or
anything that allows indexing as you
write so in this case I'm just openin up
a HD f5 file making a data set and I'm
just saying save that that that mean
aggregator array into this data set and
that'll go away in stream the results so
the original array could be bigger than
memory the result of taking the mean of
that big array over a certain dimension
could be bigger than memory and this
will still function
right so i have a small example which i
think is interesting but not necessarily
that useful where i'm going to implement
my own array-like thing i'm sorry for
everyone who can't see the bottom of the
screen and essentially i just implement
this all this class here called tile
loader and i give it an XYZ and these
are the numbers that you would use to
reference map tiles from open street map
for those of you who don't know
openstreetmap splits splits the globe
into two to the power of the zoom level
that you're interested in tiles in the
hot in the x and the y so zoom level 0
you have one tile and zoom level one we
have the globe split into four tiles so
you can give it an XYZ and what it goes
and does is when you index using get
item interface it'll go and get hold of
that URL and and give you an umpire ray
for it ok
and I can create one of these things
this is just my own object that's no
there's nothing there's no biggest here
just yet but because my my object has a
shape a data type and a number of
dimension I can put one of these things
into mine and then play arrayadapter
exactly the same way I did with an
actual limp IRA and the result is my
adapter knows its shape and its data
type okay so yeah I'm going to made one
up here actually with the width x 15 y
of 10 and a zoom level of 5 and if you
visualize that using if we realize it
into an empire ray and we can enjoy it
and we can see the top okay
so this it's already openstreetmap have
already split the the image into 2 to
the 2 to the five images yeah but what
we can do is we can fairly complex but
basically make one of these tile loaders
for the two to the Z tiles in the in the
X direction making an empire ray I'm
making a list of those and then I join
those together using the linear linear
mosaic so essentially and I'm going in
the Y direction here essentially i'm
building a column of all the images for
a particular X and then as I'm zoom
going along i'm storing the columns and
i'm joining them together again with the
linear mosaic so have this really long x
and i have produced lots of them and now
i'm doing them back together again and
the result is an array a big-ass array
so I'm just making the z nine tiles here
and the the array that the ensures is a
130 130 by three and if i'm not mistaken
i think that's about forty eight gigs
so way bigger than this macbook air can
fit that's for sure okay so what can we
do with that that array is just a
biggest array and so we can index it and
these pretty large indices here allow us
to make a smaller image from this huge
data set and again I'm just realizing it
and showing it with them show and I've
got printouts here to show you what
which tiles it's receiving no
downloading and you can see it you know
it's never actually having to realize
the bigger array it's just getting hold
of the subcomponents the smaller arrays
that it actually needs to get hold of
and and we can end up visualizing this
58 giga byte array I have an interactive
version of this which haven't put into
the ship into the slideshow but I think
I link to it right yep so in this
address there's a demonstration of this
disused case and there's the interactive
visualization where you can drag the the
image around and it will load the
appropriate tiles as you as you drag it
it's quite example
ok that's all I wanted to show you about
biggest in summary really and we've
implemented an array class and crucially
and in my opinion the the array class is
flexible enough to be able to implement
an array container which gives us the
power to hold on to an empire ray or
hdf5 variable or a netcdf variable or
just some random object that you can
create yourself so long as it's got
indexing functionality and once you've
got hold of that that array they can be
easily indexed concatenated during
together and aggregated in an efficient
way and the the aggregations can be
streamed directly to disk and
essentially reduce the requirement on on
a large amounts of memory as a result we
can refine a race of arbitrary size so i
defined one there that was fifty eight
gigabytes forty eight gigabytes and but
conceptually there's no reason why we
couldn't have a raise which have
infinite length potentially or at least
any length you so wish and obviously you
never going to be able to realize that
on your in your memory but you can work
with it you can index into it you can
even do aggregations over it yeah and as
a result of our our chunk wise
processing we can we can operate
comfortably on arrays far bigger than
can be fit in memory
so it's pretty early on we're still at
no point five point four release
actually so we've still got a lot to do
we've got a flesh outs and some ideas
that this powerful concept of
containment gives us and we think
there's there's an awful lot more to be
done with the chunking processing engine
in the background but essentially the
array interface that we've defined is
really simple but pretty complete oh i
should say biggest is not particularly
complex it's like 1,200 lines of python
code and i encourage you to have a look
if you're interested so we're pretty
excited about it I think it's something
that could really help the community
particularly when dealing with high
dimensional data arrays and yeah happy
to answer any questions you might have